ma'am okay so listen
[Applause]
I'm attract
I want to go home
and you're not going anywhere just yet
why because I already explained to you
we had somebody flag us down and say
that you were a small car okay I'm not
assaulted okay can you see it I'm not I
want to ask you your name man I'm like
you know how these things go okay
okay I want to go I'm trying to help you
I'm a cop I understand that so let me
leave with my boyfriend please just hear
me I understand your cop I get it
what more do you want I just need your
name
the incident and then we're essential on
your way but you one more you like ran
off on me because I don't want nothing
to do with you okay or cops in training
in Hamilton
I'm sorry
I'll write it down for you I'll write it
t-a-r-a
DZ
you are yeah you are KO say 421 1977.
what's your phone number Tara
you're asking me if I'm assaulted I'm
telling you I'm not okay I'm not but
when I I simply asked you earlier you're
so Irish you know why am I right I mean
pulled over from you people I'm a cop
and I don't want to be pulled over
all right
can you stay over here or no
okay well you again you're still not
listening to me
let me uh
hey Sarge
I'm live just by the way so we were
coming out of Granville and a bystander
came running up to us she flagged us
down
and she goes hey there was I just saw
somebody uh in a black truck beating up
a girl okay he just picked Rick yanked
out the parts are beating her up and
threw her back in the car and this truck
passes us coming up White Horse okay so
she goes and she goes that's it that's
it okay so we jump out turn our lights
on they start boogieing down White Horse
Hamilton and we light it up to get out
in front of this the uh the traffic yeah
he turns on Klockner like doesn't even
try to heal and we had to like catch up
to him but he's probably doing 60 miles
an hour okay we wound up stopping them
and uh you guys don't need to be fucking
stopping us it's not a third and I was
like all right well we're just
investigating something simply that
there was an allegation that you were
assaulted okay
Tara Dakota I don't know okay three
years left I don't need and I was like
all right well just let me get your
information on your side of the story
and then we'll be on our way and she'll
like flipped out on me and she like
walked away from me all right
so what do you want okay I'm nothing I
just want their side of the story and
then if she doesn't who's the guy who's
Matt sickler he's a sheriff he's a
sheriff's officer yeah where's the
calling party she's over on Grandville I
mean we
she was turning on the Grandville I
didn't stop to get her name because she
pointed the car out so I was like all
right let me just
try to grab her real quick okay stop
let's just try to stop the car I mean we
don't have I mean we don't have to call
and party but I mean no no that's all
right she identified the vehicle right
through a t we talked to him still yeah
I mean I'm gonna pull him out I mean I'm
pretty familiar with him oh you know you
know yeah
no you know so me I just got here not
you I know you how you doing
I got it done
let me talk to you here okay and I'm
Gonna Let You Go all right both of you
all right all right okay all right relax
no you have no idea
like they're talking to me like a piece
of
they got a call they didn't get a call
they got it they got flagged down and
say that you were getting so
much
I have three years left I know I know I
know and I told you I'm down I'm sure
and I told them if he was to Salt me you
would have told me under the bridge not
me I know I know that I've seen you in
action he's a cop too I know all right
but then but then it doesn't it doesn't
help but he speeds away either right no
he stopped but it took him a while all
right so that doesn't help so now my
officers they don't know who you are
you're flying like not you not you Mommy
your boyfriend I'm sorry
you're the victim you're not you're not
you're not I'm so called the victim but
you're not the victim right no okay I'm
so freaking listen to me listen to me
I'm trying and yeah
right I know you I've been on I backed
you up before on jobs I've done I've
done that
when they see you guys like I know try I
know you but you got look at relax
guy your boyfriend takes off and doesn't
stop now I think we're in a car Pursuit
right so but if there's not I'm here to
calm everybody down thank you I'm gonna
get you out of here but you but you got
to understand where these officers are
coming from all right well they think
you're getting beat up you told them no
but stop stop stop stop
no please
the guy with the glasses okay come here
come here I'm sorry yeah I know and I
have to be I have to I know and this is
not going anywhere all right I'll this
is there's nothing he did nothing wrong
but the officers well if Jason learned
how to talk to someone he's trying to
get to the bottom of it all right now
if I'm so the victim right I'm the
victim but you understand Sarah nothing
happened okay but you understand how
victims tell us that I know with you you
can take care of yourself nothing I'm
happy I've witnessed it but nothing
happened he doesn't know you all right
people tell us nothing happened right I
know and you say nothing happened
nothing happened right nothing but he
doesn't know you he doesn't know you
all right
good all right
all right are you okay
you're not fine I'm not even talking
about I'm saying are you okay calm now
with these officers look at it from
their point of view all right that's
what I'm saying
give it to me
at my point of view this is way extra
well way freaking out my car's extra
because I'm in supervisor
yeah and also I also thought that the
guy was running the guy was taking the
car he's running he was he didn't stop
and he sped away from him all right no
he's dead
all right
I'm gonna come talk to you a second can
I go talk to him
how you doing sir listen I know you're
shaking your head listen I'm not even
true but listen I'm gonna try you
Sheriff right
listen I'm I'm out here listen I'm here
to calm everybody down I know Tara right
I work with her in the city
outside
they they listen my art these are good
guys by the way you sped away
listen to me this is I'm here to talk to
Tara know her nothing happened right we
had somebody you're a share you
understand somebody flagged him down and
said that Tara was getting getting
assaulted and whatever maybe you guys
were in an argument that doesn't look
it's none of my business it's none of my
business if you're in an argument or
whatever and things whatever she's
saying nothing happened I'm okay with it
all right all right but the fact is you
can't I'm not saying you didn't stop
right away but my office is it's all on
camera right you kind of should have
pulled right over next time or right
over all right now the offices
okay
that's your first name so I'm sorry I
don't know Matt okay Matt go ahead okay
okay okay
the one that that the one that she you
hate
foreign
yeah
let me talk in the office I'm gonna set
her back in the car do you have your ID
did they take anything okay
Caitlin's fine
this is just like
you got everything you need
you guys uh we're gonna we're good I'm
gonna get them out cut them loose yeah
let me just talk to him real quick all
right